الشبكات متواصله في محيط بخمت على الرغم
من تراجع حده المعارك بشكل كبير في
المدينه التي سيطرت عليها القوات الروسيه
فهيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه قالت ان القوات
الروسيه نفذت هجومين فاشلين حول بخمه وشنت
ايضا عددا من الغارات الجويه والقصف
المدفعي تحديدا على القرى المجاوره اذا ما
تحدثنا عن بخمت عند هذه النقطه قائد
القوات البريه الاوكرانيه
تواصل عملياتها هناك مؤكدا ثقته بتحقيق
الانتصار في منطقه بخموت في بحيط بالتحديد
اما اذا انتقلنا معكم في الخارطه الى
دانيبروبي التحديد وعند هذه النقطه فقالت
اوكرانيا ان طفله في الثانيه من العمر
قتلت في هذه المنطقه وايضا جرح اثنان
وعشرون شخصا جراء الاشتباكات التي حصلت في
هذه المنطقه وايضا الاستهداف الهجوم
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات